[Music]
all right shall we call it
on small it the police no longer
consider jesse smallett a victim
cue faces covered in egg two suspects
who were apparently wearing
make america great again hats though
that has not yet been officially
confirmed
i'm disgusted by people who wear hats
that say mega
make america great again i don't like
that it's being put out there in the
media that this is a
possible hate crime and the media has
really
cast so much doubt on his story which i
find so
personally offensive and senator cory
booker said
the vicious attack on actor jesse was an
attempted modern day lynching
it's coming from the president of the
united states he's dog whistling
every day danny this is a horrible story
this is a horrible story the
circumstances is horrific
this is america in 2019
this is america in 2019 right
and here i thought it was pence's fault
feels impossible to not feel this way
right now with the president and the
vice president mike pence who like
wishes i couldn't be married
let's just be clear connect the dots
this is what happens if you are in a
position of power
and you hate people and you want to
cause
suffering to them you go through the
trouble you spend your career
trying to cause suffering what do you
think is going to happen
love during juneau meanwhile we kept
quiet
sure the idea of trumpers wandering in
sub-zero chicago at 2am carrying bleach
and a noose attacking some actor from a
show they don't even watch
without taking his phone wallet or
sandwich
seemed about as real as me joining the
view but smallit was the perfect victim
for a media
that deems any skepticism heresy
that's why these hoaxes are not rare
it's the press
orgy that attracts them now looking dumb
the media
circles its wagons at cnn they claim
that only the celebrity press
fell for this oh yeah try cnn
the washington post the la times
buzzfeed
the huffington post the daily beast
they're terrible
rolling stone slate abc poor newsweek
they ate it all up
cnn says smallit's actions set back the
movement no it didn't
maybe it set back the hoax crime
movement and that's good perhaps the
media might think first
so we'll have fewer hoaxes but don't
count on it
the media says no one should be pleased
by the events
that fake hoaxes hurt real victims but
they never mentioned the groups who were
falsely accused
seriously this could have led to real
violence against them
instead the press they parrot two lines
even if this crime isn't true here
it's got to be true somewhere else and
how awful are the conservatives for
pouncing on this now
sorry if you're sad that this turned out
to be a hoax it's only because your
network
your paper and your assumptions were
wrong
me i'm pleased a hate crime fell apart
which once again proves we are less
racist
than the media wants us to be i say once
again
because so many hate crimes are reported
then they go unreported once they're
exposed as hoaxes
and those hoaxes they are easy to find
though the media wishes you wouldn't
look
they want you to forget them like they
do every day so they can commit the same
damn mistake tomorrow